اكدت منظمه العفو الدوليه بعد منظمه هيومن
رايتس واتش صحه تسجيل المصور يظهر تورط
جنود في الجيش المصري في قتل عده اشخاص
شمال سيناء وطلبت المنظمتان السلطات
المصريه باجراء تحقيق في وقائع القتل خارج
اطار القانون ومعاقبه المسؤولين
عنها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه لماذا ترك النظام المصري امر نفي
هذا الفيديو المسرب لوسائل اعلامه ولم
يصدر اي بيانات رسميه بشانها وما
التفاعلات المحتمله لتاكيد صحه هذا
الفيديو سواء على الوضع في سيناء او على
صوره النظام المصري
[موسيقى]
دوليا
في ايام اعتاد فيها المصريون الاحتفال
بذكرى استعاده سيناء في ال من ابريل من
العام
1982 تثار تساؤلات عديده حول العلاقه بين
الجيش المصري وابناء سيناء وحول مستقبل
العلاقه بين ابناء سيناء انفسهم بعد ظهور
فيديو مسرب يكشف تورط جنود مصريين بمعاونه
عناصر محليه في اعمال قتل خارج اطار
القانون في سيناء وقد اكد صحه هذا التسريب
اهالي سيناء ومنظم العفو الدوليه وهيومن
رايتس وتش بينما وصفته وسائل اعلام
المصريه بالمختلط للانتقاص بما تدعوها
الضربات التي توجه للارهابيين في سينا
المزيد في تقرير ناصر اي
الطاهر دعك من القانون وصفي معارضيك انها
سياسه ممنهجه او هو كما يسميه حقوقيون نمط
متكرر من القتل خارج اطار القانون اثار
فيديو سين المسرب الذي كشف بعضا من تلك
الممارسات في مصر كثيرا من الجدل لكن
التسجيل الصادم وجد ما ينصفه انه صحيح
تقول كبريات المنظمات الحقوقيه الدوليه
التي حللت محتواه فقد جر التعرف على مكان
تصويره والتاريخ التقريبي لذلك وكذا هويه
شخصين من قبيله رميلات ظهرت في الفيديو
عمليه اعدامه وتم التعرف ايضا على الشخص
الذي استجوب احد المقتولين برفقه جنود
النظاميين وهو من عناصر الميليشيات
البدويه المتعاونه مع الجيش والشرطه في
شمال سيناء او ما تعرف محليا بصحت سيناء
او البشم او المندوبين تطالب منظم العفو
الدوليه وهيومن رايتس واتش تبعا لذلك
السلطات المصريه بالتحقيق في عمليات
الاعدام خارج اطار القانون ومعاقبه
المسؤولين عنها لكن القاهره لا تزال تلتزم
الصبت صمت قد يقطعه على استحياء حديث غير
رسمي ينقل تفنيدا لصحه الفيديو عن مصدر
يصفه بالسياده وذاك ما تقول به علانيه بعض
من اذرع النظام الاعلاميه لكن منها ما لا
توقفه الفبركه المزعومه عن التحريض على
عمليات القتل خارج نطاق القانون ده لا
يمكن يكون جيش مصر ولا يمكن وبرضه مره
ثانيه وانا تاني بقول وعاشر
اي ارهابي
يقتل ما يدعو اليه من ممارسات تغلف
بمحاربه الارهاب تصاعدت بتولي مجدي عبد
الغفار وزاره الداخليه في مصر لكن من
المتابعين من يعتقد ان الضوء الاخضر
للتصفيات الجسديه اضاء لاصحابها من هنا
قبل عامين ايد
العداله الناجزه مغلوله
بالقوانين واحنا مش هنستنى على
العداله كما فهمها بعض المؤتمرين بامره
انعكست اعتقالا عشوائيا واختفاء قسريا
وتصفيه لمعارضي نظامه في عموم البلد يعرف
اهالي سيناء تحديدا عما نتحدث منهم من راى
ابناءه المختفين قسريا قتلا وقد لفقت
وقائع مداهمات او مواجهات للتغطيه على
اعدامهم خارج اطار القانون والمحاكمات قد
يفسر ذلك غضب المجتمع السينا المتصاعد
والذي بلغ ذات مره حد التهديد بالعصيان
المدني وتلك مواجهه ليست في مصلحه السلطه
ولا حربها المفترضه ضد التنظيمات المسلحه
هناك وحتما لن يكون في صالحها ولا صالح
البلد جر منطقه حساسه كهذه الى فتنه قبليه
حتى الان تدفع بذلك الاتجاه الاستعانه
بادلاء ومتعاونين محليين يشاركون جنود
النظاميين انتهاكاتهم في
سيناء موضوع حلقتنا اليوم نناقشه مع
ضيوفنا في الاستديو الدكتور سيف الدين عبد
الفتاح استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
القاهره من اسطنبول الناشط الحقوقي المصري
هيثم غنيم ومن القاهره عبر سكايب المحامي
والناشط الحقوقي والسياسي اسعد هيكل اهلا
بضيوفي الكرام وابدا بضيفي من القاهره
السيد اسعد هيكل سيد اسعد بغض النظر عن
صحه هذا الشريط او كونه مفبركا الا تجد
مضمونه
خطيرا لا نستطيع ان نغض البصر عن صحته او
كونه مفبرك هذا الفيديو مفبرك جمله
وتفصيلا سناتي الى هذه المساله سناتي الى
هذه المساله ولكن فقط اجبني على سؤالي هل
ترى مضمونه
خطيرا ليس فيه اي خطوره هذا امر مكشوف
ومعلوم هذه حرب نفسيه تشن ضد الجيوش
العربيه بدات باسقاطه حل الجيش العراقي
والان بمهاجمه الجيش السوري والتشكيك في
قدراته ومحاوله حله كما حدث في العراق
والان يحاولون النيل من الجيش المصري اخر
الجيوش العربيه المحتفظ بقوتها ووحدتها
وسلامتها ا المساله المساله في غايه
الخطوره سيد اس اسعد ومع ذلك لم يصدر ل
ليس ليس هناك سمه خطوره الجيش المصري
والشعب عندما تقول سيد اسعد انا مازلت معك
عندما تقول بانهم يريدون للجيش المصري نفس
مصير الجيش الليبي او الجيش السوري وما
اعطيته من امثله هذا يدل على ان ما تضمنه
الشريط بغض النظر عن كونه صحيحا او مفبركا
يحتوي اهدافا لنقل خطيره ومع ذلك لم يصدر
اي بيان رسمي من الجهات الرسميه حتى يكذب
او يفند او يرد على ما تضمنه هذا الشريط
ما ما تبريرك برايك ولن يصدر بيان هذه
امور اقول لك تح يحدث في اطار الحرب
الحديثه الحرب الاعلاميه ببث واستخدام
الصور المفبركه على شاشات التلفاز وانا في
الحقيقه لا ادري يعني يعني ان يكون
التركيز على الجيش الاسرائيلي وممارساته
في غزه مثلا او ما يحدث من الميليشيات
المسلحه في سوريا ضد الجيش السوري العربي
يكون امر مقبول ان نبرز هذه الممارسات لكن
ان نبرز وان نركز على شريط بسته قناه
تابعه لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين نحن ندرك ب
مقاصد هذه القناه ومقاصد هذه الجماعه التي
تعمل من اجل اهدافها الخاصه بالاستقواء
بالخارج لكن لا نتفهم في الحقيقه ان يبس
هذا الشريط عبر قناه الجزيره ويعاد بسه
مره واثنين وثلاثه الامر الاخر ان كل من
يطعن في الجيش المصري ويحاول اتخاذ من هذا
الفيديو وسيله للطعن في هذا الجيش وفي
شرفه وعزته هو انسان خائن
لوطنه بغض النظر عن هذه اللغه السياسيه
انت تشكك في صحه هذا الشريط فقط لانه بث
من قبل جماعه الاخوان وكما قلت من قبل
قناه الجزيره هل هذا هو الدليل الوحيد على
ان هذا الفيديو
مفبرك لا هناك من الادله الكثير لكن نحن
تجاوزنا هذه المرحله بكثير نحن الان نتحدث
عن حرب موجهه ضد الامه ا هي حرب موجهه
دكتور سيف الدين عبد الفتاح اذا من
البدايه عدم رد الجهات الرسميه كما يقول
ضيفي من القاهره على هذا الموضوع لانه
موضوع يبدو انه خلق من العدم الهدف منه ان
يكون مصير الجيش المصري كما قال ذم
القاهره هو نفس مصير الجيش السوري او
الجيش الليبي ولما تغطون الطرف عنما يجري
من الجيش الاسرائيلي كما قال ضيفي وان كنت
لم افهم هذه المقاربه ولكن بالنسبه له
الموضوع خلق من العدم وغير موجود انا اظن
انه الفكره التي تتعلق
بالقداس التي تحيط بالعسكر يجب ان
تنتهي ليس ذلك الامر يت تعلق هنا ب لا كما
يقول بخيان او شيء من ذلك القبيل ولكن
بممارسات حقيقيه يقوم بها العسكر وانا هنا
افرق بين العسكر والجيش او بين العسكر
والمؤسسه العسكريه العسكر هم قاده هذه
الجيوش الذين يتلاعبون بها ويجعلون لها
دور غير ادوارها هذا هو الامر هو ده
العسكر الذي يريد ان يحكم ويتحكم اما
الجيش فهو الذي يحمي الحدود والوجود ولكن
قبل ان نصل الى هذه النتيجه ضيفي يقول بان
الجهات الرسميه لم ترد لم تقدم اي رد على
هذا الموضوع لانه انا اظن انا ا هوعدم
سواء نعم لا اظن ان هذه حاله استخفاف
بالجمهور بوجه عام حاله من التعتيم اعتاد
عليها هذا الجيش اذا كان الامر غير في غير
صالحه الامر هنا يتعلق بما مسائل اعلاميه
كثيره يقوم بها هؤلاء من اعلام الشؤون
المعنويه وفي كل الاحوال انا اؤكد على ان
هذا الشريط كما اكدت مثل هذه المنظمات
التي لا نستطيع باي حال من الاح لها ادوات
تتعلق باثبات صحه هذه الشرائط لان في
الشريط في هذا الشريط وفي غيره فضائح
ويسند هذا قرائن لا تستطيع اطلاقا ان تقول
وكما راينا في التقرير الكلام عن ان
القانون يغل يده ومن ثم هو لابد وان يتحرر
من ذلك القانون ايضا الاعلان حاله الطوارئ
على هذا الش الشكل في سيناء من قبل ثم بعد
ذلك في عموم ارض مصر كل هذه المسائل اذا
انت تبني صحه هذا الشريط على توفيقه من
قبل منظمه العفو الدوليه وكذلك هيومان
رايتس وتش ومن خلال ال شهادات القبائل في
س وهنا اسال ضيفي السيد هيثم غنيم كيف
يمكن البناء على ردود الفعل هذه في توثيق
هذه الماده الفيلميه وما المراد
منها طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اعتقد
ابتداء ان الماده الفيلميه دي اول دليل او
ثاني دليل عملي يطلع من سيناء ولكن الفرق
ما بين الدليل الاولاني والدليل الثاني ان
في الدليل الاولاني في شريط كان صرب قبل
ذلك برض من سيناء كان في اثنين من بدو
سيناء بيتم تعذبهم وكان احدهم مصاب بطلق
ناري في في قدمه ثم اعلن المتحدث العسكري
بعدها بايام ان هؤلاء قد قتلوا في
اشتباكات مسلحه مع كمين احدى كمان
العسكريه في منطقه شمال سيناء لكن الجديد
في الشريط اللي احنا بنشوفه دلوقتي ان
عندنا ثمان اشخاص تم اعتقالهم وا اخفائهم
قسريا ولدينا اسماء الثمانيه ومنهم اثنين
من القصر يعني اعمارهم احد احدهم عمره 16
سنه بيتم انزاله من عربيه من عربه عسكريه
تابعه للجيش المصري ثم يتم اعدامهم ويتم
تصوير هذا هذا الاعدام ثم بعد ذلك لدينا
بيان للمتحدث العسكري يتضمن صور هؤلاء
القتلى ويقول المتحدث العسكري في بيان
عسكري خطي مكتوب على الصفحه الرسميه
للمتحدث العسكري وايضا في شريط فيديو قام
قامت الصفحه الرسميه ايضا للمتحدث العسكري
بنشره وقام موقع وزاره الدفاع على
اليوتيوب ايضا بنشره بيقول ان ه لاء
الاشخاص الثم الثمانيه اشخاص قد قتلوا في
اشتباكات مسلحه في قريه التومه في منطقه
في محافظه شمال في شمال سيناء طيب ما الذي
يمكن ان يبنى عليه الان طبقا لما قامت به
منظمه العفو الدوليه وهيومن رايتس وتش وهم
اكبر منظمتين حقوقيتان في في العالم
بمراجعه هذا الشريط واثبات انه ليس بمفك
كما قال او كما ادعى الضيف اسعد هيكل عكس
عس عكس ذلك يمكن الان المطالبه بوقف
المساع دات العسكريه التي تقدم للجيش
المصري من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والدول الغربيه الاخرى
والتي قتل مدنيين خطوه بخطوه في هذه
الحلقه سيد اسعد هيكل استمعت الى م قاله
ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو وكذلك ضيفي السيد
هيثم غنيم فيما يتعلق بهذه الماده
الفيلميه الى الان مازلت مسرا ان الموضوع
لا يستدعي اي رد فعل رسمي رغم مطالبه
منظمات دوليه كمنظمه يوم رايس او منظمه
العفو الدوليه على اعتبار ما يجري في
سيناء هو نزاع مسلح وبالتالي سيؤخذ
قانونيا ودوليا بمقياس اخر نعم يعني انت
تريدني ان اسلم بصحه ووجهه نظر الدكتور
انا لا اريد شيئا انا فقط اسالك ولك ان
تجيب كما تشاء انا لا اريد منك شيئا انا
انا المساله ليست الشخصيه بيني
وبينك يعني انا احدثك كمنبر اعلامي لكن
انا اجيب على الدكتور سيف واقول له يعني
من العار في الحقيقه عليك كمصري ان تستند
الى تقارير منظمات دوليه مشبوها تتلقى
تموتها حتى وان كان من قتلوا مصريين ومن
اليهود حتى وان كان من قتلوا مصريين لحظه
لحظه هذه مساله اخرى انا اتحدث الان عن من
يستند الى تقارير لمنظمات دوليه مشبوهه
مموله تمويلا صهيونيا ليطعن من خلال هذه
التقارير في جيش بلده هذه مساله في
الحقيقه حل اسف كبير ان تحدث من دكتور سيد
اسعد سيد اسعد سيد اسعد حتى لا تكون
المساله شخصيه وانت وانت تعرف بان الموضوع
خطير انا اسالك انا اسالك في قضيه في قضيه
اثارت ردود فعل دوليه ويمكن ان تاخذ ابعاد
اخرى وانت ترد على ضيوفي بشكل عاطفي انا
اسالك بالرد بشكل منطقي وسياسي وانت رجل
سياسي رغم خطوره الوضع لا رد رسميا على ما
جرى ما تفسير ذلك لا عاطفيه ولا شخصيه انا
قلت في البدايه ان الذي بس هذا الفيديو هي
قناه تابعه لجماعه الاخوان وحينما اتحدث
عن الدكتور عبد الفتاح او غيره فانا اقصد
جماعات تعمل ضد الدوله المصريه تستقوى
بوسائل اعلام تعمل على تشويه الجيش وصولا
الى محاوله النيل من ترابط الشعب المصري
مع قوات المسلحه وليكن في الحزبان ان كلنا
كمصريين كلنا كلنا الجيش المصري مدنيين
وعسكريين ولن يستطيع احد ان يلال من وحده
الشعب المصري مع جيشه لكن ان نستند الى
تقرير مثل هذه المنظمات علينا اولا ان
نبحث عن من هي هذه المنظمات نبحث عن جورج
سورس مثلا وتمويل لمنظمه هيومان رايت واتش
نبحث عن الدول المتحكمه في منظمه العفو
الدوليه نبحث عن الادوات التي يقول عنها
الكتور سيف انها توصلت من خلالها هذه
المنظمات الى حقيقه الحقيقه المزعومه لهذا
الفيديو ما هي هذه الادوات انا اسال
الدكتور س ربما ربما انا اسالك ولكن انا
ربما اسالك ولكن انتظر اجابتك بعد الفاصل
ماذا لو هذه المنظمات وثقت ما تقوم به
الجماعات الاخرى تنظيم الدوله في سيناء
وقالت بانه يقتل المدنيين هل ستصبح وثيقه
ل لديك ولد الدوله المصريه ام لن تكون
وثيقه هذهه المنظمات الموصوفه بالمشبه كما
وصفتها بعد الفاصل سنناقش التفاعلات
المحتمله لتاكيد صحه الفيديو المسر عن
تورط جنود في الجيش المصري في عمليات قتل
خارج اطار القانون سواء على الوضع في سينا
او على صوره النظام المصري دوليا نرجو ان
تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد دكتور سيف ما تضمنه هذا
الشريط ماده خطيره بغض النظر عن تاكيد ما
في الماده من قبل منظمات دوليه وكذلك
اهالي بعض اهالي سيناء او التشكيك من
الجهات الرسميه عن طريق وسائل الاعلام
المصريه او حسب ضيفي من القاهره الشريط
خطير حتى نهيك عن مساله القتل خارج
القانون الشريط يؤثر حتى على التركيبه
العشائريه والسكانيه في سيناء ماذا عما قد
يعكسه هذا الشريط وعن تفاعلات فيما يتعلق
سواء في الصعيد الداخلي المصري داخل سيناء
او على صعيد الدولي نعم هذا السؤال غايه
في الاهميه بس اريد ان اوجه حديثي للضيف
في القاهره على ان لا يكون شخصيا لو تك لا
يعني انا بس عاوز يتكلم بحجه لكن لا يطلق
هذه الاوصاف على عواهنها هكذا و بيعلمني
انا اتكلم ازاي انا بتكلم بمنطق وبحقه ان
كان لد حجه فليقل هو لا يريد ان يفتح
الموضوع من الاصل تحت دعوه الفبركه وانا
اقول ان هناك هيئات ومنظمات هو يقول عنها
انها مشبوهه ولكن هذه منظمات دوليه وصلت
الفكره اذا السؤال المهم الذي تطرحه انما
يتعلق
بالطريقه التي يتعامل بها النظام مع سيناء
وهذه مساله شديده الخطوره نحن كنا نتحدث
ان سيناء لا يمكن ان يحفظ هذا الوطن وهذا
الجزء من الارض الوطن الذي يشكل بوابه
للامن القومي المصري الا بتوطين ست ملايين
من اهل مصر في هذا المكان ذلك ان المساله
التي تتعلق بتعمير سيناء هي الكفيله
بتحقيق المساله الامنيه الامنيه من خلال
عمليه تنمويه هذا هو الاصل الامر المشكل
الحقيقي الذي يتبناه هذا النظام انه يتخذ
من ذلك مساله امنيه حتى ان هناك بعض
الصحفيين اشار على على المنقلب السيسي
يقول له ببساطه شديده اخل سيناء تماما وكل
شيء سيكون هدفا ان بقى في سيناء سيكون
هدفا هذه هي المساله لمصلحه من تخلى سيناء
ولكن لمصلح وهذا هذا السؤال لمصلحه من جيش
مصر الذي حرر سيناء وكل سنه يحتفل بذلك ما
مصلحته بان يخلي سيناء في اقل من 20 ثانيه
نعم للاسف الشديد ان جيش اكتوبر الذي كان
يمثل شرف الو الوطنيه والشرف العسكريه
المصريه اصبح الان جيش البزنس وانا اؤكد
على هذا وجيش البزنس الذي يقوم باعمال مثل
هذا في الانخراط في السياسه والاقتصاد عن
عن هذه عن هذه الصوره اسال ضيفي هيثم غنيم
عن ما الذي سيتفاعل بعد هذا الشريط
وتوثيقه من قبل منظمات دوليه و ماالها من
من
وزن طيب خليني الاول اعلق على الكلمه
لدكتور سيف قالها اللي هو جيش زنس ا وناك
ان على على النقطه دي منطقه التومه اللي
حصل فيها عمليه التصفيه دي واللي تم تهجير
الاهالي منها هي احدى المناطق اللي الجيش
واضحه في خطط التنميه الاقتصاديه التابعه
ليه في خريطه اصدرتها اداره المساحه
العسكريه تبعه للقوات المسلحه المصريه سنه
1996 كانت الخريطه بتتحدث عن منطقتين جيش
يجب ان يتم استهدافهم في التنميه الصناعيه
وهي منطقه ابو زنيما في منطقه وسط سينا
ومنطقه محيطه بقريه التومه او منطقه
التومه في جنوب العريش و ورفح وغرب وغرب
رفح والشيخ زويد في المنطقه دهت النهارده
في 25 ابريل القادم في في احتفالات اعياد
تحرير سينا هيتم افتتاح بعض المشروعات
الصناعيه اللي قامت القوات المسلحه
المصريه بانشاءها في منطقه ابوزنيمه
واعتقد ان القادم هيبقى في تلك المنطقه
اللي هي منطقه التومى اللي كان فيها شريط
الاعدام ده تعليقا على ا ان الجيش كيف
يتعامل او لماذا يق الجيش باستهداف
المدنيين واخلاقهم قصرين من بعض المناطق
اللي خارج المنطقه الحدوديه اللي قام
باخلاقها سابقا النقطه الاول النقطه
الثانيه والخاصه بسؤال حضرتك وهي كيف يتم
البناء على على مثل
هذه الاثباتات والدلائل والقرائن الماديه
اولا التحركات الدوليه يجب اولا ان
يتم رفع قضايا على جميع الشركات التي
ستتعاون مع بتصدير الاسلحه للجيش المصري
كما حدث سابقا في مثل احداث محمد محمود
سنه 2011 في مساله قنابل الغاز وما وما
الى ذلك ايضا اعلم ان هناك من يعمل الان
ويتواصل على على هذا الفيديو مع بعض اعضاء
الكونجرس الذين سياخذ مناقشه عنما قريب في
مساله الدعم العسكري المصري وهنا ليس
نتحدث عن خيانه للجيش المصري وما الى ذلك
ولكن نحن نتحدث عن جيش يراد له من ان
يتحول من مؤسسه عسكريه الى شيات مسلحه ودي
كارثه مصر ماشيه لها على سي ساعود لك ولكن
فقط ا ضيفي في القاهره ايضا لاستمع الى
رايه سيد السعد هيكل يمكن التغطيه على ما
يجري في سيناء بحكم القوانين العسكريه
المطبقه في سينا ولكن انا تعتقد بان هذه
التغطيه وهذه التعميه لن تستمر طويلا
ستظهر ايضا اشرطه اخرى ووثائق اخرى ربما
قد تدين بشكل او باخر ما يتم سواء من قبل
هذا الطرف او ذاك في
صينا يعني لا تعميه ولا تغطيه هذه منطقه
عمليات
عسكريه يريد لها البعض ان تتحول مثل سوريا
وتتقاتل
الفصائل وتتقاتل الميليشيات كما هو حادث
في سوريا وهذا لن يحدث باي حال في الاحوال
في مصر لكن يعني انا عايز اعقب بس على
العباره اللي بيقولها الدكتور سيف جيش
البزنس يعني كان مرسي الرئيس الاسبك الذي
زل الشعب كان يصفه بجيش من ذهب الان تتحدث
عن البزنس ولم تكن تجرؤ ان تتحدث هكذا بان
فتره حكم جماعه الاخوان ولكنه الهواى هو
اله انت تتبع الهوا فيضلك عن الحق لم تكن
تتحدث عن هذا حينما كانت جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين تحكم وتصف
الجيش دكتور سي ع ثواني فق لك
الحق حق ان ترد حتى اذهب الى ضيفي نعم
يعني انا انا اظن ان هذا نموذج من نماذج
غسيل المخ التي تحدث لا يناقش الحدث ولا
المضمون ولكنه يحاول التهرب من الموضوع
ككل في محاوله للحديث عن الاستقواء بالخام
وان هذه منظل في اقل من 20 ثانيه هل لك
انتكم فكرتك التي كت كنت تقولها قبل
قليل استاذ
هيثم ايوه نعم تفضل نعم فقد سالتك ان كنت
تريد ان تكمل فكرتك في اقل من 20
ثانيه تمام ولكن خليني ا اتحدث سريعا عن
الفيديو استاذ اسعد هو بيدعي ان هو مفبرك
نعم نعم ا خليني اعطيه اثنين من الاسماء
اللي شاركوا في عمليه الاغتيال وهو جندي
عمار محمود يستطيع المؤسسه العسكريه
المصريه ويستطيع من يبحث عن الحقيقه ان
يستوجب هذا الجندي وكان حاضر لعمليه
الاعدام وايضا ا
الفرد التابع لميليشيا مجموعه 103 وهي
ميليشيا تابعه للقوات المسلحه المصريه وهو
من قام بتنفيذ اطلاق النار على رؤوس
المعتقلين واسمه ابراهيم حماد العرجاني من
قبيله
الرابينج الوقت كما اشكر ضيفي من القاهره
اسعد هيكل واشكر ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور سيف الدين عبد الفتاح شكرا جزيلا
لكم الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]
ن